[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport c'est parti pour le sommaire de
ce à magazine football en deuxième
division de district villes pro a perdu
sur son terrain contre l'équipe réserve
de versailles le score 2 à 0 une défaite
qui pourrait intégrer les espoirs de
maintien des villes provient les détails
dans son étude sport basket un match
amical entre deux écoles a déchaîné les
passions jeudi dernier à versailles mais
600 personnes sont venues assister à la
rencontre entre auch et sainte-geneviève
focus sur cette rencontre inédite
automobile libinois jean pierre garcin
originaire de montesson a réussi à
boucler son 21e rallye raid comme
copilote aux côtés de christian
lavieille
le duo a terminé à la 28e place de cette
épreuve disputée en arabie saoudite nous
recevrons dans cette émission
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres
focus sur la coupe des yvelines de
football deux matches n'ont pas eu lieu
ce week end montigny le bretonneux
maurepas et coignières vélizy ont été
déplacées dans les autres rencontres
bailly noisy a battu maisons laffitte
sur le score de 7 buts à 0
héricourt s'est qualifié aux tirs au but
contre eux et l'encours on continue par
de la 2e division de district c'était le
match à ne pas perdre pour villepreux
les joueurs recevaient une équipe
réserve de versailles sur leur terrain
mais les villes posément plus rien pu
faire pour éviter à la défaite le résumé
du match faisait images de marylène
aille à pishin aux deux équipes et un
même objectif survivre dans ce
championnat de d2 deux districts il pour
recevait la réserve de versailles ce
dimanche 9 février après une première
période équilibrée ce sont finalement
les versets y est qu'ils arrivent à
faire la différence
1 à 0 ce sera le score à la pause un
résultat ces versements les villes
président la première un but refusé
injustement tu nous aura permis au moins
de garder la distance vitres refuser
l'équipe n'est sorti du match et après
voilà on n'a pas manqué en amont a
manqué d'occasions d'en manquer de
volonté et le vent qui nous a beaucoup
gênés car générer des équipes au retour
des vestiaires sous une pluie battante
et le vent les deux équipes ont du mal à
produire leurs meilleures partitions
faire ça et réalisera tout de même le
break score final à 2 à 0 satisfaction
des trois points après le travail sur le
terrain était compliquée avec les
conditions météo l'un vend pas possible
maintenant sa satisfaction des trois
points on est tellement mal placé dans
le classement par rapport au projet de
chemin qu'on avait prévu que les trois
points c'est le plus important
au classement l'équipe 3 de versailles
est toujours 11e et revient à hauteur
des premier non relégable
de son côté villes pro est toujours bon
dernier avec une seule victoire depuis
le début de la saison ils ont pris un
petit coup
maintenant faut pas relâcher il ya
encore des matches à jouer la saison est
encore long on n'est jamais n'est jamais
à l'abri d'un d'un miracle pour
continuer à croire au miracle villes pro
se déplacera sur le terrain de montesson
le dimanche 1er mars ont joué également
à quelques étages plus haut en régionale
3 en match en retard trappes n'a pu
faire mieux que match nul contre
l'équipe réserve de poissy sur son
terrain score final 2 partout au
classement trappe reste 11e du
championnat et doux
ce point mais l'équipe conserve ses
chances de maintien en fin de saison en
nationale 3 à versailles consolide sa
place de leader les joueurs de la cité
royale se sont imposés à 2 à 0 à
domicile ce samedi contre le club
d'aubervilliers
une victoire qui leur permet d'occuper
la première place du classement avec
quatre points d'avancé sur le second
ivry prochain match ce samedi sur le
terrain des mureaux pour un derby il y
avait hâte également du handball ce
week-end en nationale 2 féminine le club
de montigny le bretonneux s'est imposé
28 à 25 à domicile contre aulnay in
algeri chacha une nouvelle fois été
énorme avec 9 buts inscrits ce résultat
propulse lésigny monteyne à la troisième
place du classement en embuscade à
seulement un point de la seconde place
toujours handball mais cette fois ci
chez les garçons en nationale 3 plaisir
a perdu 28 à 27 sur le terrain de paris
sport club malgré les six buts de dylan
faustin amis à tout l'ida au classement
à plaisir est toujours 8e avec cinq
victoires en 13 matches depuis le début
de la saison
des images de course à pied à présent le
cross de la sablière fêter à sa 39e
édition à viroflay le 2 février dernier
au total à 1052 participants dont 550
moins de 18 ans participent à l'épreuve
organisée dans la forêt de meudon et
versailles le cross long de 11 km a été
remportée par abdellah ait omar du club
de vélizy villacoublay en 45 minutes et
47 secondes
chez les femmes caroline chupin de
viroflay remporté l'épreuve rendez vous
l'année prochaine pour une 40e édition
on prend maintenant à la direction de
versailles pour parler de heath porte un
tournoi était organisé pour la troisième
fois dans la cité royale
l'après midi ou 200 passionnés se sont
retrouvés pour s'affronter par écran
interposé un reportage de mélanie poké
et grégory et canal et des places prisé
et un public qui répond présent la
troisième édition du tournoi il porte a
de nouveau fait le plein ce week-end
plus de 200 joueurs se sont affrontés
durant tout un après-midi amateurs comme
professionnels
bilan c'est que j'appelle judo du monde
a fait j'avais mon niveau et ça m'a fait
plaisir
le but c'était de jouer très content
parce que je pensais pas passer le
premier tour final je vais passer assez
facilement je suis sorti premier de ma
poule
du coup fier de moi quand même je vais
très très jeune on a besoin d'eux entre
guillemets agrandir la communauté est
donc là ça me permet de rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes et puis de jouer
avec des joueurs que j'affectionne après
deux saisons tourner autour de hearst au
le tournoi s'est ouvert à de nouveaux
jeux du football avec fifa 20 et league
of legends le numéro un du monde de
l'ispor qui vient de fêter ses 10 ans
[Musique]
les choses
l'idée c'était que les jeux c'est un peu
comme des disciplines sportives
on a beau être sportif si on joue pas au
rugby on va pas forcément sur le rugby
donc là l'idée c'était d'avoir plus de
diversité plus de personnes qui étaient
intéressés mais pas forcément sur un
seul jeu donc là ça a permis d'avoir des
communautés trois joueurs on peut
imaginer que nos rentrées de cap et les
vainqueurs se sont partagé près de 4000
euros de dotation les équipements déjà à
une quatrième édition hameau de
taekwondo à présent l'école de trappes a
performé ce week-end lors des
championnats de france seniors quatre
jeunes ont participé à ce rendez vous
deux sont revenus avec des médailles
calida ada2 revient avec la médaille
d'or et inesta raoui remporté le bronze
à seulement 15 ans le club participera
le vin les 22 et 23 février prochain à
l'open d'helsingborg en suède
on va maintenant ouvrir une page
gymnastique pour sa première année
d'existence le club baptisé les clés gr
a remporté quatre médailles dont une en
or aux championnats nationaux
individuels une folle est qu'ils se sont
disputés à massy en janvier pour nous
parler de ses attraits bon résultat nous
recevrons la présidente cécile est ainsi
que gladys faisait nos clients une
monitrice dans le club et dorothée
traoré bonsoir
alors comment réagissez vous à ces très
bons résultats
on est très fier parce que nos gymnastes
est long
vraiment performer elle travaille
beaucoup et le travail paye donc
vraiment on est très content d'eux pour
elle et on trouve que les monitrices ont
fait du très bon travail
voilà donc franchement très satisfait
est ce que ces résultats étaient
attendus ou pas du tout était très
souhaitée en tout cas oui on en
attendait pas le temps s'arrête pas
autant pour une première année en plus
on était très très fière d'elle en tout
cas et qu'est-ce qui a fait que ça
fonctionne et justement ben elles ont
réussi leur passage parce que la grs et
il faut savoir passer ce temps une fois
né sur le praticable il faut que ça
passe le ballon ne s'échappe pas il faut
pas perdre le cerceau font pas perdre
ses moyens et donc bah là ça a marché
alors ceci laisse son 10è 1 le club est
tout nouveau
pourquoi avoir créé cette structure
parce que donc avant on était avec lui
sm c'est donc la structure
union sportive municipale des
clayes-sous-bois et on a souhaité
prendre notre indépendance parce qu'on
n'arrivait plus à travailler ensemble
donc on est parti et finalement ça se
passe très très bien
gladys comment se passaient cours
justement depuis depuis y est la rentrée
va très très bien déjà dans l'équipe il
ya une très bonne cohésion avec la
présidente toulon et à ses proches
on n'est plus vraiment une petite
famille donc tout se déroule pour
l'instant au mieux
dorothée ce que vous senti qu'il y avait
un besoin aux clayes-sous-bois alors
pour la gymnastique divine demande il ya
toujours une demande domestique
rythmique maintenant comme le disent et
cécile
il y en avait qui il y avait quand même
une offre par le biais du snc grs mais
là maintenant qu'on est passé en hand
façon de travailler de façon autonome
on a tout autant de demandes voire
peut-être même plus puisque ont offert
des nouvelles sections éveil et adultes
notamment et du coup on récupère quand
même pas mal d'adhérents et tout se
passe pour le mieux pour moment
justement combien de licenciés alors
alors à peu près de 100 entre 210 et 220
adhérents
voilà donc 80 à peu près fond
font de la compétition on voit les
images de compétition c'est pas
forcément le cadre pour tout le monde
sait ça non on a beaucoup de jeunes qui
font du loisir en fait on a donc des
éveils qui ont trois ans qui commence en
fait c'est de l'éveil corporel
ensuite on a des babys points entre 4 et
6 ans donc là c'est pareil pas de
compétition en corse et de l'activité
ludique pour se dépenser pour apprendre
les bases du placement et du maintien
pour pas se faire mal et ensuite à
partir de 6 ans on peut soit faire du
loisir soit commencé à faire de la
compétition
donc on a quelques gymnastes ont 6 7 ans
qui commence à faire des mini poussines
et ensuite ça évolue au fur et à mesure
nous conseiller à partir de quel âge
pour les enfants le lait ça des trois
ans des trois est déjà à venir avec nous
et comme ça on continuera de les former
quelles que soient leurs intentions
qu'ils soient compétitifs ou en
challenge on commence par quoi en
général pour leur donner envie il faut
leur faire toucher à tout parce qu'au
départ les petites filles peuvent être
attirés par les rubans les garçons au
départ par tout ce qui va être les
petite roulade est en fait chacun y
trouve son compte y laisser un petit peu
de tout ce soit au niveau des engins
cerceau ruban corde ballon et le fait de
travailler avec des ateliers au parcours
c'est vrai que ça c'est intéresse
beaucoup
quels sont les objectifs du club pour
les prochaines années afin de continuer
comme cette année et même envoyer encore
plus d'équipés d'individuels ont
complètement ça c'est sûr et puis bah
voilà voir le nombre d'adhérents
augmenter puis que tout se passe aussi
bien que pour cette année en tout cas
pour ce début d'année beaucoup de
médailles
je suppose ben là nous on est très fiers
d 4d quatre médailles
après on va voir ce que ce qui va se
passer en
pour les indes pour les compétitions en
ensemble mais on espère bientôt jeudi
françois d'avoir des médailles ben ça
aide à se donner de la motivation est et
on voit que le travail du coup paye
quand il ya une équipe qui réussit on se
dit ah on peut les prendre comme modèle
et puis l'année d'après c'est pas les
mêmes équipes qui vont re et qui vont
bien marcher donc c'est c'est bien alors
vous allez également organiser une
compétition régionale jeunesse le 26
avril prochain
est ce qu'on peut nous en dire un peu
plus alors c'est une compétition pour
les enfants qui ont entre 6 et 11 ans le
thème ça sera sous le soleil normalement
quand on va pouvoir décorer la salle
voilà l'idée c'est vraiment de faire une
rencontre festive et pas une compétition
juste pour avoir des premiers des
deuxièmes des troisièmes il ya un
classement par par groupes d'enfants
c'est à dire que les enfants qui ont
très bien réussi auront des médailles
d'or sur un peu moins bien des médailles
d'argent et ainsi de suite
donc l'idée c'est vraiment c'est le
développement de l'enfant est pas la
compétition juste 4 et son sportif c'est
ça sur la compétition oui alors vous
organise également des stages aussi
pendant les vacances
oui on organise un stage pendant les
vacances de pâques qui est ouverte à
tous et à toutes
donc qu'on soient adhérents ou pas des
rangs on peut venir s'inscrire et
essayer la grs merci à toutes et 3 bet
passé sur ce plateau on vous souhaite
beaucoup de réussite pour la suite et
surtout beaucoup de médailles du
football américain à présent les temples
idées en cours se sont imposés à 28 à 14
sur le terrain des dragons de paris
cette deuxième victoire de la saison en
trois matches permet aux élans courtois
d'occuper la première place à égalité
avec les léopards dos rond et les
dragons de paris en basket en nationale
2 féminine l'entente le chine et
versaient remporté sa onzième victoire
de la saison contre l'équipe de
geispolsheim sur le score de 56 à 50 une
petite victoire mais une victoire
précieuse les yvelinoises sont toujours
deuxièmes du classement à deux points de
la première place
ont joué à également en nationale 3
masculine le chesnay versailles a marqué
100 points contre marly le roi avec
notamment 47.2 bamba cei le genre de 41
ans est l'un des meilleurs scoreurs de
même nationale 3
dans ce côté trappe s'est imposé 85 à 72
contre le club de rueil athletic club au
classement trap est toujours 3e et le
chesnay-versailles quatrième marly le
roi reste bon dernier
on continue à parler à deux baskets et
d'un match qui a fait trembler les murs
du gymnase au mont boron de versailles
la semaine dernière deux écoles de
classes préparatoires versaillaise je
vais sainte geneviève et auch se sont
affrontés dans un match amical de basket
qui a réuni plus de 1600 personnes en
montage de sandrine fontaine un match de
basket
unique en france ce jeudi 6 février deux
écoles versaillaise sainte geneviève et
auch se sont affrontés dans un match
amical digne des plus grandes ambiances
universitaire américaine dans la salle
1600 supporters chauffés à blanc c'est
ma seule année là on a on attend ça
depuis deux mois
aulas a fait une semaine on pense plus
qu'à ça on a oublié toutes les matous
toute la physique et où on est là pour
gagner
l amicale mais bon faut juste qu'on fait
juste lutte d'influencé
ce match de basket inédit a été créé il
ya une quinzaine d'années sur le modèle
des grandes rivalités universités anglo
saxonnes
le rendez vous oppose aujourd'hui des
jeunes de 18 à 21 ans mais ça reste
avant tout des élèves de classes
préparatoires aux grandes écoles
donc qu'ils vont aller vivre plus tard
polytechnique centrale les mines hec
mais là c'est instants pour eux c'est un
partage sa souvenirs à vie
gravé pour créer encore plus de
souvenirs les organisateurs ont vu les
animations grand dans ce gymnase mob
auront spectacle de pom pom girls
mascotte d'un soir speaker et star du
basket français
j'aurai avec weiss ancien joueur de
l'équipe de france a fait le déplacement
depuis limoges spécialement pour
l'occasion
on m'a dit que c'était une ambiance de
folie pour l'instant je suis pas déçu
j'espère que ça va continuer c'est très
bien pour le basket c'est très content
alors bien sûr il ya des rivalités mais
moi je suis pas dans ça j'ai plus de
temps dans l'admiration parce que le
match s'est finalement terminée par une
victoire de l'équipe de ginette face à
auch sur le score de 65 à 46 pour
l'année prochaine les organisateurs
prévoient un show encore plus grand
m
[Applaudissements]
on va maintenant parler à de sport
automobile et plus précisément de dakar
les viennois jean piat garcin originaire
de montesson réussi à boucler son 21e
rallye raid comme copilote aux côtés de
christian lavieille
le duo a terminé à la 28e place de cette
épreuve disputée en arabie saoudite nous
avons la chance de recevoir l'yvelinois
sur ce plateau bonsoir jean pierre
garcin bonsoir
alors vous avez donc terminé à 28e sur
cette compétition sur votre toyota est
ce que vous êtes satisfait de ce
résultat tout simplement oui on est
satisfait parce que l'on court dans une
catégorie de véhicules de série et c'est
pas du tout la même chose que le
prototype qui sont devant donc le
challenge est complètement différent le
niveau c'est un véhicule de série qu'il
faut ménager
tous les matins on part en pensant déjà
là en premier à être arrivé le soir sans
trop abîmer la voiture parce que on peut
ne pas changer on peut pas changer
certains éléments mécaniques donc faut
vraiment père préserver la voiture et
s'est pas particulièrement facile
surtout pour le pilote je veux terminer
tard le soir
non termine jamais très tard on met
quand même bien organisé on va finir
entre 17 et 19 heures mais bon on est
retourné en arabie saoudite sur le
continent africain
mais ce qui nous change par rapport à
l'amérique du sud c'est qu'il fait nuit
de bonheur il faisait nuit vers 17 17h30
et surtout il fait froid ça a changé vos
habitudes ça changer nos habitudes
surtout qu'on est retourné un petit peu
sous la tente donc les nuits sont
fraîches 4,5 degrés donc c'est vrai
qu'on n'était plus très préparé à ça
alors vous avez également terminé
premier dans la catégorie t2 des
véhicules de série emerson c'est ça
ouais c'est un challenge que d'un toyota
japon c'est un petit programme sportif
qui existe depuis une vingtaine d'années
et eux ils s'en servent essentiellement
pour communiquer en arabie saoudite
parce que c'est un gros marché pour eux
en chine au japon chez eux bien sûr est
un petit peu en russie aussi est-ce que
terminer un dakar c'est une victoire en
soi pour tout le monde c'est une
victoire parce que c'est le premier
challenge surtout pour les amateurs
parce que les amateurs souvent ils n'ont
pas les possibilités d'assistance que
les usines
ils sont peut-être un petit peu moins
bien préparés donc pour vraiment la
victoire c'est de finir quoi ça sont le
taux de réussite de finisher en général
7 50 à 60 % tous les ans alors vous en
avez parlé brièvement l'arabie saoudite
c'était une première cette année est ce
que il faut y retourner
oui fou rire de la guerre va être obligé
d'y retourner partenariat voir tourner
parce que déjà je pense qu' on va y
aller 4 5 ans et franchement le paysage
au lac terrain de jeu jusqu'à 2024
le terrain de jeu est fantastique pour
nous en tout cas et c'est toujours une
ouverture pour le pays de nous voir on
vient là on est une caravane de 2500
personnes
il ya des femmes qui sont pas voilées
qui sont en tee shirt
c'est très bon enfant et on a plutôt été
surpris de l'accueil la population
plutôt positif plutôt positif
les gens étaient très curieux venez nous
voir ils savaient pas trop que ça avait
lieu chez eux
mais petit à petit il a commencé à avoir
du monde dans les spéciales parce qu'ils
ont quand même beaucoup de 4,4 à bail
des airs immense et il venait nous voir
non franchement c'était sympa est-ce que
vous pouvez nous parler de votre
coéquipier sens baca en équipier si on
l'avait christian lavieille c'est un
ancien champion du monde d'endurance
moto que voilà qui a fait une belle
carrière en endurance moto qui a
travaillé beaucoup pour les
constructeurs et il s'est fait une
petite reconversion petit à petit en
voiture il a couru en circuit il a fait
plusieurs fois les 24 heures du mans etc
etc découvert la passion du rallye raid
parce que le rallye raid c'est un peu
une drogue quoi une fois qu'on ya goûté
on a du mal à s'en passer
soit ça plaît pas et puis dans ce cas là
on vous fait qu'une fois c'est niais oui
moi j'ai l'impression d'être tombé
dedans et non c'est vraiment une passion
c'est le voyage et à la découverte des
gens on rencontre beaucoup de monde
c'est beaucoup un travail d'équipé parce
que nous devons faire il y en a qui
conduit en haïti copilote mais à côté de
ça et des mécaniciens soir il ya manager
pour s'occuper de tout ça non ça
représente un vrai travail l'équipe donc
c'est très sympa justement va voir à
l'image votre premier dakar c'était en
on va voir l'image voilà justement
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque 97 bas
c'était la rencontre avec une personne
qui m'a proposé de le faire déjà c'était
bien et je lui met trois minutes pour
réfléchir et j'ai même pas demandé à ma
femme je dis allez c'est parti
après c'était des dakar en un batteur à
l'époque qui était très difficile quoi
c'était très long on l'a par contre ont
rentré très tard le soir sur ton
amateurs mais de la première année après
le souci c'est que on rentre au moins de
janvier fin janvier et après on pense
qu'à une chose c'est comment on va
repartir à vide après quoi il est
également ceux des cas en 2013 c'est
l'un de vos meilleurs souvenirs 2013 ses
meilleurs souvenirs parce que j'étais
parti avec guerlain chicherit qui était
un skieur un ancien skieur de descente
et on a eu on a fait une belle course
dans quelques petits soucis mécaniques
mais on a gagné une spéciale coin voilà
donc quand on gagne spécial ou dakar et
qu'on n'est pas forcément professionnel
c'est toujours oui quelque chose
d'émouvant pas vrai ça très bon souvenir
c'était au pérou en plus premières
années au pérou s'était c'est
exceptionnel alors je rappelle vous êtes
co pilote
oui vous n'avez jamais voulu être qu'ils
n'ont jamais fait du sport automobile
dans ma jeunesse en amateur voilà après
faut avoir un talent quoi et franchement
j'ai pas s'éteindre là donc c'est
beaucoup plus agréable d'être à côté de
vrais pilotes mais
et puis de faire son travail de façon
professionnelle et non c'est mieux
franchement quelle est votre travail
avoue justement dans ce travail c'est sa
maman
on dit que c'est pas un travail mais bon
je serai pas le plus riche du cimetière
mais j'aurais passé beaucoup de bonnes
années j'ai roulé avec pas mal de
pilotes alors ça vient doucement
au début on fait plus je travaillais
plus dans la mécanique ou dans la
logistique etc
puis petit à petit la place du co
pilotage prend une part de plus en plus
important alors c'était votre 21e biaka
est-ce qu'il y en aura d'autres
oui j'espère j'avais dit qu'il
arrêterait à 25 m
voilà donc il reste 4 je ne sais pas si
j'arriverai c'est pas physiquement mais
après c'est trouver une place que ce
n'est pas forcément facile le marché de
copilote payer quand même relativement
étroit mais bon je veux l'espoir qu'est
ce qui vous pousse à continuer justement
bon toujours la même chose la passion
l'envi je dis je lis toujours dit mon
épouse et mes enfants
le jour où je n'aurai plus envie je
serai plus voilà parce que c'est trop
pénible ça peut être pénible voilà donc
faut vraiment avoir la passion avoir
l'envi mais je sais que là on est rentré
il ya 15 jours et que dans un mois on
pensera plus qu'à une chose qu'est ce
qu'on fait l'année prochaine oui déjà
partir oui oui bon j'espère qu'on fera
d'autres choses parce que le programme
avec toyota comporte en général des
essais le rallye du maroc au mois de
septembre
donc bon ce héros on se remet vite dans
le bateau de façon bien objectif de
victoire
est-ce que c'est envisageable alors non
parce que le marché dans les voitures de
tête est quand même relativement boucher
est bon à mon âge je dirais que je suis
bien content détail toyota dans ce
programme t2 qui est peut-être moins
valorisants sportivement mais qui reste
une belle aventure et une belle aventure
humaine
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
janvier un gars 1 je rappelle vous avez
terminé à 28e de cette épreuve mythique
le dakar hameau de rugby à présent
retenez bien son nom fabien a vite ce
jeune morlaisien de 19 ans est
aujourd'hui en équipe de france des
moins de 20 ans le sportif qui a débuté
au mesnil à saint denis a été
sélectionné pour le tournoi des six
nations dans sa à catégorie il était
remplaçant mais il est entré en
lord saville de la victoire de ce
week-end contre l'italie à aix en
provence
avant de partir il a participé à notre
désormais à traditionnels jeux et des
trois questions regarder
[Musique]
un entraînement ouvert au public
au menu saint denis au départ c'est mon
frère qui était censée s'inscrire et moi
j'ai voulu essayer ça m'a beaucoup plu
et j'ai un peu
à force et auprès des parents pour
qu'ils puissent s'inscrire j'avais pas
là je mets
et les entraîneurs ont fait une
dérogation parce qu'il m'avait apprécié
et du coup ils nous ont demandé des
dérogations à lier ça a été accepté j'ai
pu jouer du coude beac a fait une grosse
envie et un petit peu de forçage nos
dépens
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir ça notre
le titre de champion de france à 7 avec
avec moi si en 2016
on a bien rigolé sur 60 mois
[Applaudissements]
comme chaque joueur présent si c'est
arrivé au monde professionnel et réussir
à vivre du rugby le plus longtemps
possible et puis continuer dans ma
passion ou même préparé un peu l'avenir
et pourquoi pas finir sans dans une
école de commerce dans le milieu du
commerce pendant ou en travers d'une
d'une belle équipe de rugby qu on passe
maintenant notre page agenda on commence
cet agenda par duo rugby en fédérale 2
plaisir va recevoir au stade robert
barran le club de jeunes lillois ce
dimanche à 15 heures la rencontre
s'annonce électrique les deux équipes
sont au coude à coude et lutte
toutes les deux pour le maintien en
fédérale 2 un seul petit point à l'essai
par plusieurs centaines de supporteurs
sont attendus pour l'événement on jouera
également sur les terrains de fédérale 3
verset se déplacera sur le terrain de
vincennes ce week-end pour le compte de
la 15e journée du championnat et
versailles reste sur une excellente
dynamique avec trois victoires sur les
cinq derniers matches des résultats qui
permettent pour l'instant au club
d'occuper la troisième place de sa poule
pour la conserver ils devront battre le
septième vincennes on termine par une
bonne nouvelle pour la ville de poissy
la commune va cueillir le jeudi 23 avril
le variétés club de france lors d'un
match amical
la rencontre caritative devrait être
organisée au stade léo lagrange on
retrouvera notamment sur la pelouse
didier deschamps et des champions du
monde 98 dans les tribunes on retrouvera
à brigitte macron le variétés club de
france était déjà venu à poissy 7 et en
2018 s'élève déjà à la fin de cette
émission merci l'avoir suivi passé une
excellente soirée sur tva 68
[Musique]